so we have two three by three matrices
here matrix a
and matrix b and we could of course view
each of them
as a transformation in three-dimensional
space
now what we're going to think about in
this video is the composition of
a of b so you could think of this as the
transformation
where you apply b first and then you
apply a
after that and then we can represent
that by another 3x3 matrix
which is partially completed here we
have the first and the third column here
and so my question to you is what is
this middle column where i have these
three blanks pause the video and try to
work through that
all right now let's work through this
together
so one way to think about how to
construct a of b
is that what you're doing is you're
taking each of the columns
of b and you're thinking about what
would they be under the transformation a
so if you were to apply the
transformation a
to this column right over here you would
get
this column if you apply the
transformation a
to this column right over here you would
get this column
so what we really need to do is apply
the transformation a
to this column to the middle column
right over here
and just as a reminder how this
transformation works a vector
0 2 3 you can think of it as
0 of the
1 0 0 vector the unit vector in the x
direction
plus two of the zero
one zero vector plus
three of the zero
zero one vector now when you apply the
transformation instead of using
these unit vectors you use the image of
them
under this transformation and now in
this situation instead of a 1
0 0 vector we are going to be using
this thing instead of a 0 1 0 we're
going to be using
this thing instead of a 0 0 1
we are going to be using this thing
so this middle column what is
transformed by this vector is going to
be
zero instead of the one zero zero one
it's going to be zero
of the negative three negative three
three vector and then we have plus two
plus two of the zero
let me do that in that purple color of
the zero negative two
three vector and then last but not least
you're going to have three
of the plus three of them i'll do that
in yellow
the zero negative four
one vector now we just quote do the math
so when you apply zero times all of this
you're just going to have a 0 0
0 vector so we can those all go away and
then you are
left with let's see this one is going to
be
2 times 0 is 0. 2 times negative 2 is
negative 4.
2 times 3 is 6. you're going to have
that
plus 3 times 0
is 0. 3 times negative 4 is negative 12.
3 times 1 is 3. i could have written
this a little bit neater but hopefully
you get the idea
and then when we add those two things 0
plus 0
is 0. negative 4 plus negative 12
is negative 16. 6
plus 3 is 9.
and we're done we have just completed
the composition
of a of b